I'm like and I created servicer service
that really started out of necessity I
couldn't get to the ocean I really loved
the way that the body type and the
fitness level that I attained while
serving so I needed to create a workout
that can mimic that this is your
three-minute serve set workout hey this
is Mike from Surfside fitness and I'm
here for your three-minute balanced
workout on the river surf for X so first
thing I want you to do hands on the
rails sides on the surfboard walk one
foot up two feet up come up push up
through the spine bend those knees
shoulders back core engaged all right
all I want you to do just walk the board
out little side to side get used to it
we're going to bring that left foot
right into the middle we're going to
point that toe call these water walkers
push through stabilize in the whole way
so I write to wobble let's go three two
just drag those toes along the long
ground and one all right now we're gonna
bring that right foot back in that left
foot off this time
stabilize core engage right quads going
same motion we're going to turn it to
the right okay so a little bit more
balance based here we're going to sink
down nice and tight okay core is engaged
now we're going to hop is we called
exploding squats so we're gonna hop up
hop out up up up out
we're not elevating just making room by
bending the knees gauging that core
let's go three two and one okay we call
these toe curls so we're gonna bring the
hands down to the rails we're gonna kick
that foot all the way to the back tuck
the knee point the toes and hold once
you're balanced and if you really got it
single leg squat push it all the way up
or if you want to go a little bit more
controlled we're going to push and pull
return to that first position so up and
back point the toe nice job I'll bring
that right foot same position wherever
we do to one side we do to the other
now from here we're going to go on a
split squat stance so that right leg is
coming back now that left knee is behind
that big left toe just like we're in a
split squat stance okay so from here
let's bring that right leg forward and
up up back let's go three each leg has
one two three stabilized switch feet
bring that left knee forward and back
find that motion let's go two more one
two nice job we're going to come down
grab the rails here what we're going to
do is called crow we're going to grab
the rails on the side use those elbows
when you use those as our platform we're
going to come up find the toes and if
you're really good
that's all I got all right so that was
your three minute surf set balance
workout so first move water walkers
second little bit exploding squats and
then there's toe curls we're gonna go
into split squats and then there's crow
got a little bit of core we've got some
balance with it some flexibility add a
bunch of fun this is my car Wickham surf
set thanks for checking it out make sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any other fighting weight episodes